[Music]
before we start
a quick reminder that if you enjoy what
we're doing then you should take up a
subscription offer
to our magazine we're europe's fastest
growing politics and current affairs
publication
you can subscribe for a pound a week and
get a free
20 pound amazon voucher i mean i can't
do better than that
it'll give you access to all of our
articles podcasts
and newsletters as well as instant
delivery of the magazine buyer
the spectator app every week to take up
this offer
now click the i button in the top right
hand corner of this youtube video or go
to
spectator dot co dot uk forward slash
trial
now on to the main event spectator tv is
new
but it's already a channel with
influence last week i spoke to the
swedish epidemiologist
and just tegnal he devised sweden's
policy about
not going into a full lockdown downing
street which listened to it and saw it
was intrigued enough by what he had to
say
that by sunday night the prime minister
was himself
consulting professor tagnall not clear
however
that he listened to what the professor
had to say on today's episode there is
as always these days
of shortage of things to talk about the
chancellor has cancelled his
november budget today he gave us a mini
economic statement
instead a winter economy plan he said it
was
wep we'll be breaking down the numbers
and what he had to say
the new plan from the treasury comes in
the wake of this week's further
covert restrictions and an alarming
press conference
by the government's chief scientists on
monday they claimed
that we're heading to 50 000 daily
infections by the
mid-october actually they didn't quite
claim that
it's what they implied by the grass that
they showed are we really doing that
we'll investigate some tory mps are
asking much the same question as to
whether it's happening
and they're trying to force the
government to give them more of a say
in the country's covert strategy i'll be
speaking to
graeme brady he is the sort of chief
shop steward for the tory back ventures
and he's leading this effort to give
back bench mps more of a say
and moving away from home and covert
we'll also be asking whether or not the
uk should be following a more
american approach on the problem of iran
and of course it wouldn't be spectator
tv without hearing from you our viewers
were growing in numbers every week over
150 000 last week
let's see if we can break that this week
please send your questions
uh in via the youtube live stream
and we give our thanks to the natwest
group for their continued support
for this program that west is the
biggest supporter
of businesses across the uk is working
hard during the pandemic to help
businesses and personal customers
get through this difficult time
now first that economic statement this
afternoon
until very recently in other words a few
days ago the treasury was planning
for a full-on budget in november
but all that changed pretty fast with
number 10 put in new
covert restrictions that will make life
harder for many people and
businesses for perhaps another six
months
on monday the government's chief
scientist chris whittie and patrick
balance
they justified the move in a press
conference because they claimed that by
mid-october
new covert cases could be rising at a
rate
of 50 000 a day could be they said
implying with the graph that it would be
and
assuming that most of fleet street as it
dutifully did
would say it was a prediction of 50 000
a day
so we move from that to cue the
chancellor's emergency statement
in the house of commons today it
replaces
the november budget are his
announcements the chancellor's
announcement enough to tide over the
economy
in the months ahead what's he up to i'm
joined by kate andrews the spectators
economics correspondent
she also edits the spectator's daily
covert 19
update it's a lunchtime newsletter with
the latest numbers
and news on the pandemic from around the
world over a hundred thousand people
already get it
you should to to keep up to date okay a
lot of numbers being uh flying around
from the
in fl infection rates to the
chancellor's
new proposals can you break them down
for us i can do my best for you andrew
i'm just going to share my screen for a
short slideshow
as you mentioned it's been a very data
heavy week
and that all kicked off when the
chief scientific officer patrick valens
and the chief medical officer chris
woody decided to show
this graph at their press conference
earlier in the week which showed one
scenario
in which cases nearly hit 50 000
by mid next month now they insisted this
wasn't a prediction but a scenario it
was very notable that no other scenarios
were shown and many have asked why not
especially when we've been told for
weeks
that the uk is following the same
trajectory as france and
spain and if you were to show those
scenarios when you multiply the cases
in france and spain and project them
onto the next three weeks
you see a very different kind of curve
there now of course
anything can happen that really can't be
said enough but you'll note that that's
a very different scenario than the one
that was laid out
earlier in the week and of course we can
track the uk's cases
day to day but here we've done a seven
day rolling average as it's easier to
see the curve
and you can see that so far actually it
looks like our case is maybe slightly
higher than where france was
but at the same time we are nowhere near
the curve that was shown
earlier in the week and there's a lot of
talk about infection rates and there's
no doubt that in all three countries
infection rates are going up when you
look at the hospitalizations however you
can see yes there is a small
uptick as well but still very much in
the capacity of
the national health service and
one thing that could make cases spike
however and you know many things could
many things could keep them down
we're simply in the dark on a lot of
these things um is a
is a pre-print study led by louise smith
from king's college london along with
other researchers
from king's college london and ucl um
which is looking at
let's call them stated preferences
versus revealed preferences and this is
adherence to self-isolation
over the months of july and august this
graph showing after developing covid19
symptoms not necessarily testing
positive and you can see that
well over the majority of people vast
majority of people there did intend
to self-isolate if if they found that
they had symptoms but you can see their
entry that
roughly 15 percent did um perhaps even
more concerning
after being told to quarantine by nhs
contact tracing because
they had been in contact with somebody
who was found to test positive for copen
19
again the vast majority said that they
would or intended to self-isolate and
roughly
11 did um so this will all be weighing
on the mind
of the chancellor and and leading up to
today's
winter economy plan the staple
of this was the job support scheme which
is
now going to replace the furlough scheme
when that comes to an
end on the 31st of october from the 1st
of november
employees working a minimum of 33 of
their normal hours will be entitled to
subsidies
of those hours not worked a third will
be paid by government a third will be
paid by the employer
and a third will be foregone now some
immediate changes there that you can see
you have to be working in order to get
the subsidies
you can't be not working and notably the
government and the employer has switched
places as to who the financial burden is
falling
most heavily on previously under the
furlough scheme the government was
paying over 50
of an employee's subsidized wages now it
will be the employer
i think it's also very notable how much
money is projected to be spent
on what the chancellor announced today
we haven't seen any official figures
from the treasury yet but capital
economics suggests that it could be up
to about 5 billion pounds now
that's no small sum of money but of
course compared to the furlough scheme
which is so far
cost nearly 40 billion pounds it is
relatively small
and even compared to the summer
statement when the chancellor announced
the
job retention bonus and incentive to try
to keep
employees in work employers will get a
thousand pounds for every employee they
kept on
into the new year you're still looking
at less money being spent
now of course the chancellor did insist
again today as he has done in the past
but i think even more so today that he
cannot
save every job this is actually new data
today
monthly data showing how many employees
are still on furlough
you can see there uh 3.7 million
just about now that's significantly down
from the 9 million at the height of the
furlough scheme
but an important reminder that when the
furlough scheme ends
even with this new scheme it is
certainly not the case that every job
will exist after we come out of the
furlough
and i think the chancellor's trying to
walk a fine line uh
between still trying to support
businesses to keep on their employees at
least part time
but also recognizing that at some point
we have to transition if these jobs
don't exist now
we have to move people into new jobs as
painful as that might be
and the last thing i would just know as
i stopped sharing my
slideshow is that we have not yet seen
an updated scenario from the
office or budget responsibility about
how quickly the economy is going to
rebound but
what we do know from the the heavy
hitters the bank of england the obr
is that they've slowly been revising how
quickly they think the uk will make a
comeback and
if you're an optimist you might say that
it still looks like a v
but many people would question why a v
tails off at the end maybe looking a bit
more like a nike tick
and no doubt with any restrictions
coming in which i know we're discussing
on the show tonight
that will be another damper really on
economic recovery
okay thank you for that and we'll come
on with we have a cambridge academic
joining us to look at these what i would
call the valence witty numbers
on getting to 50 000 cases a day by the
middle of october
so let me ask you some questions about
the economy
even with the so he's moved from
furlough
to a job subsidy and as you your graph
really showed the government's role in
this is a lot less than it was
when it was shelling out for furlough as
it still is to
to for a few weeks yet um it seems
though that even with this new scheme
there's pretty much no question that in
the
as we go through the autumn unemployment
is going to arise
almost no doubt andrew um and that is
the
sad reality when you have an economic
contraction the largest in
300 years when you're in a very serious
reception recession
we know that unemployment goes up and we
are starting to see
the numbers tick up month on month um i
think the chancellor is hoping
that this new scheme will be a bit of a
cushion to the cliff edge that the end
of the furlough scheme
would have been but it is not designed
to to save every job you can also tell
it's not designed
for an economy in hibernation it's
designed for an economy that should stay
relatively open albeit it's going to be
painfully
limping towards recovery perhaps not
surging upwards and there's still a lot
of support there but it's not designed
yet anyway
for an economy that is so restricted
that it essentially has to shut down
again
i do think one thing's worth noting
especially for the fiscal hawks out
there is we've been told
that this is supposed to essentially be
wartime spending a huge
one-off spending spree for these covered
measures but this new scheme
now ticks into the next next fiscal year
it's from six months from november
so we're talking about spending that's
going to be taking place next year as
well
now so far it's nothing like what we've
seen but this idea that it really is a
one-off spend is going to
be i think put under question more and
more and if this starts to turn into
structural
deficits and structurally very high
spending the government's in an even
stickier financial situation
than it already is james
i saw the institute for fiscal studies
saying that there could be another
2 million unemployed by the end of the
year
is the the government must be worried
that here we look these are exceptional
circumstances it's probably happening
all over europe
but it must be a bit worried that our
tory government
the political fallout of becoming
synonymous once again
with very high levels of unemployment
yeah i think that's why you see
that richie sunak constantly emphasized
that his priorities jobs jobs jobs you
know
he called the statement today a plan for
jobs and i think what you see here is
this is an attempt to encourage
companies to keep staff on
you know rather than keeping one person
on working full-time
keep three members of staff on working a
third
each and if you look at the way i think
their hope is that this will interact
with the
the thousand pound bonus you get for
bringing someone
back from the furlough to full-time work
and that will help
keep unemployment down i think the big
challenge going forward is this if you
look at uk job creation in the 2010s
which was astonishingly good
lots of the majority of those jobs were
produced in retail and hospitality
those are the two sectors which i think
will take the longest time
certainly high street retail to come
back from
covid and so this is the challenge the
challenge is not
job retention i think it is job creation
and it is a struggle to see right now
where these new jobs are going to come
from because
part of the problem is that lots of the
shifts that are happening in the economy
retail spending is back but the online
share of that spend
has increased massively online retail
just fundamentally requires
fewer people to be employed in it than
high street retail
kate katie uh
is there a division now between number
10
and number 11 between boris johnson and
rishi sunak
on the trade-off between lockdown and
the economy
have we got us are we going to split
here
i think we're beginning to see a split i
mean
i think there's definitely a difference
of opinion now when you talk about the
locked and doves and the hawks matt
hancock is often the chief dove
and richie cena is seen as a chief hawk
now i think that's fairly understandable
in the sense
that if you look at their departments
they're brief clearly rishi
next is going to be thinking about the
economy matt hancock is going to be
thinking about their nhs
and health i think when it comes to
number 10 however
i think ultimately boris johnson is
taking a very risk-averse
approach as far as he sees it i think
there's a sense in downing street that
they can't really be too cautious
and particularly if you look at what
happened last time in terms of the very
high death toll
boris johnson might not say sorry
publicly but privately a lot of people
do admit that they made mistakes
and i think that does create attention
to your degree it was interesting you
mentioned in your introduction
and over the weekend they have had
different
scientists and different figures with uh
different opinions on coronavirus come
and give
advice to rishi sunek and to boris
johnson
that included anders tagnam also carl
hannigan who's been on the show
sinatra gupta and i think that in a way
that was partly because you have figures
such as the chancellor
and other cabinet ministers saying there
is more than one view out here
we shouldn't just take everything as a
given so i think it has had an
impact but i think ultimately boris
johnson when he is faced with the two
different crises is always going to opt
for the health one
and i think there is a concerning
downing streak particularly because
right now i don't think
we're seeing all the economic damage
that they just cannot take a risk on a
on a route which puts the economy
further forward
just in case it does have that backlash
in case you have that big death toll
again i think that
boris johnson's number one concern is
trying not to repeat what happened the
last time
and therefore that is creating a very
cautious approach which i don't know
which i don't believe is the one the
chancellor would choose kate how has the
chancellor statement gone down both in
the city
and among his own supporters and
the opposition and the commons is it
felt he's done enough for
now he hasn't done enough uh
what's the reception be
katie go ahead kate kate andrews oh okay
um i i actually think it's going down
very well
there's a sense that he has opened up
the gap and this sounds
this sounds tough but it's true he's
opened up the gap for certain jobs to
slip
through and by that i mean if your
employer is not able to pay you to even
work part-time they're not able to put
up just over 50
of your costs then those jobs are
probably going to go
and this is part of that very painful
transition
so this isn't a c an economy that's
hibernating but it's not one that's
necessarily going to be
flourishing either but at the same time
he's created a buffer as more
restrictions come in that say allow
hospitality to operate but give it a
curfew
uh 10 p.m that they have that bit of
flexibility to bring people back slower
to rotate their shifts and actually to
try to keep more people on staff
so i think it's felt that this is the
right next step especially now that the
prime minister has said
that these restrictions could be with us
for at least another six months
but i think we have to watch this space
because as the chancellor himself said
in july to the house of commons you
cannot be in a position where the
government is indefinitely
subsidizing workers wages he made that
case then to not extend the furlough
scheme
he hasn't it's not really a u-turn but
it is a scheme where the government is
still
actively paying a part of workers wages
so when we get to march april may next
year
you would think a very different tomb
would have to be whistled at least by a
conservative government
okay we shall see let's move on because
of course
only about six seven weeks ago by
september
we were meant to see the continued
gradual opening out of the economy we
were meant to be
on a pathway of a return to normality
things
would be getting better not worse that
uh we could leave the furlough scheme
without even a job subsidy scheme
and none of that has happened now
because of the new infection numbers the
government scientists
trotted out this week as cade has
explained this is
only one scenario patrick valance
himself repeated
the number was not a prediction but i
kind of think
the government must have thought the
media would take it as a prediction
because it was the only scenario that
was
given and it was presented as supporting
the government's stricture rules which
were then
introduced in its aftermath so is this
alarmism with the help of scientists or
is it prudent
i'm joined now by someone who can
interpret the numbers for us dr
flavio talks ver not content with being
an economist
he's also an expert in epidemiology
combining the two disciplines
in his research at cambridge university
uh flavio before i get you to interpret
the figures can you
explain briefly how is economics
combined with the epidemiology and
what insights does that give us sure
thanks thanks for having me
so people like myself economic
epidemiologists have two main
areas of research one is to understand
the interaction between infectious
diseases
and the economy at large so the kind of
stuff we're talking about today
and the second one is to use
tools and ideas from economics and
economic theory to
inform the um policy to contain diseases
so for example we study things such as
what are the
on to which extent will there be
spontaneous social distancing
what are the effects of a lockdown what
is the optimal lockdown
how do you phase it and so forth so
these are in some sense
cost benefit type analysis the the the
twist is that rather than doing it
say for building a bridge you do it in a
context of infectious diseases
and where the interventions rather than
being say building an infrastructure
is to for example close down a factory
or part of the economy
right well let's take that expertise and
look at this
50 000 new infections by the middle
of october it wasn't a prediction
but it was presented as a scenario and
as i understand it
the underlying assumptions one of the
reasons they came to this figure was one
what was already happening
uh and two looking at what was happening
in spain
and france uh which are deemed to be
two to three weeks ahead of where we are
on the curve
my problem with this though doctor is
that what's already happening is not a
doubling every seven days
though that's the projection and what is
happening in france and spain
is not a doubling every seven days of
new
cases so am i missing something on the
assumptions
well maybe i should introduce or rather
start by saying is it's difficult to
make predictions especially about the
future
but uh the maybe to understand um
where these numbers come from we need to
understand how they are created
so maybe i can just bring you back to to
march where the imperial college study
it predicted that we were going to have
of the order of 500 000
deaths and if you look into into the the
uh
the actual communication by the this
group of scientists it was quite clear
that what they were looking at was a
worst case scenario
so that means they made very specific
assumptions about the
the behavior that individuals in the
population was going to exhibit
so in particular the the numbers were
projections
of what would happen in a world in which
people had
absolutely no incentive to protect
themselves against the infection
and so doing that what you get is you
get very very dramatic numbers because
of course people are not
protecting themselves they're just going
out and and
and mingling with others and getting
infected at very high rate
now in practice what we know is that
people actually do things
to protect themselves and therefore that
alone that
that intrinsic desire of individuals to
protect themselves and their families
will tend to actually curb the infection
numbers away from that worst case
scenario
so in some sense the reason that they
they keep insisting that these are not
predictions
is that they don't have a very good
handle
on what people are going to do this is
an under researched area
within epidemiology and public health
there are
uh they're beginning to be studies that
look at these things looking for example
at social distancing data from google
looking at credit card transactions data
where we can actually trace people's
behavior in real time
as they respond to the epidemic and it's
quite clear
from from that new research that a large
amount
of the decrease in activity came not
because of the lockdown
but actually preceded the lockdown for
one or two weeks
i'm certainly puzzled by this emphasis
on new cases at the height of the
pandemic all the talk was of deaths if
you look at the press conferences
which the politicians were giving every
day with the
two scientific advisors others brought
in
at times the emphasis was very much on
deaths because deaths were very high
cases were high too but deaths were what
worried us
now all the emphasis is on cases
not on hospitalizations
it doesn't seem the nhs is anywhere near
being overwhelmed
not on deaths because despite the rising
cases
deaths are very low and it makes me
suspicious
that casey's are now the new metric
getting the evidence
rather than the others because and i may
be wrong here
the others don't play into the narrative
that the government would like us to
follow
is that too cynical well i don't know
maybe
maybe
slightly but the maybe the the change in
emphasis
has to do with the fact that early on uh
there were still a lot of things that
were unknown about the disease for
example
we had very very poor grasp of whether
this was the asymptomatic
rate how many people were actually
infected we also had a very poor
uh grasp of the um infection fatality
rate
that is how deadly the disease was and
it's quite possible that they wanted to
earn the side of caution
at the early stages because there was a
real fear that
the nhs was going to be overwhelmed and
therefore the natural focus was on death
numbers
now as you as you rightly point out the
nhs is although it is on the strain is
certainly not being overwhelmed
and maybe that has you know prompted a
slightly
loosening of the narratives that were
from your judgment what are the chances
that we could hit 50 000 new cases a day
by the middle of next month so
i i'm reluctant to uh to replace one
sketchy forecast with another sketchy
forecast
i i think uh uh i i think i i'm
confident to say that i don't think
we're going to see the kind of numbers
that um
that um that are being projected or that
are being
presented to us as the worst case
scenario but in order to to
make a proper estimate of these things
you have to conduct a proper
empirical analysis you don't do this on
the back of an envelope
in fact i think it's it's fair to say
that there's been more economic research
firepower
at any run-of-the-mill uh you know
um kind of reform of
the housing sector or the hospital
sector than there has been
in this particular pandemic i think
there's been a complete disconnect
between on the one hand the people are
looking at the economic numbers
and the people who are looking at the
health issues and and if i may just
point out one one interesting thing that
katie said earlier
you mentioned that there were two crises
here economic epidemiology actually
think of this as one crisis
which which has interacting features you
can't
think of either the economy or the
epidemic in isolation because
there's such strong feedback effects
between these two uh different crises
that we think of it as one crisis and
the important thing here is that
to understand the situation we face in
terms of trade-offs
grand trade-offs not just in terms of
you know we got to save the economy and
then let rip with the deaths
or vice versa
some people are saying that the lockdown
should have been tougher
are there figures to justify that or has
the government
done enough or perhaps even too much for
the foreseeable future
well i think there's there's a consensus
that maybe
the measures that were brought in were
brought in maybe a bit late
and it is not clear that um
in hindsight that a total block you know
a total lockdown of the entire economy
might have been the best way to go about
it i think what we have learned
is that we maybe want to emphasize
better targeted policies
so regional policies or policies that
target specific sectors or
specific professions rather than having
a blanket
lockdown but i think also in all
fairness in the very early stages of the
epidemic
there was a scarce knowledge about the
details
and one can if one wants to be
charitable you can say that we were
trying to buy
time to better understand the situation
we were facing
and in such a situation closing down
everything
and trying to take a breather and figure
out where we're standing might
have been an and a sensible thing now
going forward
uh i think an a a good argument can be
can be made there might be better ways
of um of managing the situation than a
complete lockdown and i think
one this uh this pre-print that was
mentioned earlier
about adherence to social distancing
measures i think this is extremely
interesting because
what it shows us is that people do not
necessarily do what they're told
and so that suggests a very obvious
policy level which is
that if you want people to be careful
and and not
you know infect each other maybe you
should start by providing the right
incentives
for them to actually behave responsibly
and that
has you know both stick and carrot the
stick of course
is that you know we might want to impose
actual fines on people
who are not you know doing their bit on
the one hand and in terms of carrot
we can think of furlough schemes or um
statutory sick pace
as actually being instruments that make
it easier for people
who have symptoms to stay at home rather
than to go out
because there's strong evidence now that
that people actually
despite having symptoms they go out and
put others at risk
so so i think there are many many policy
levels we need to explore before we go
to the nuclear option
of closing down everything again now
back bench revolt there are many ways in
which a second wave will be different
to the first wave of covet back then
when we first had it in march april may
the government passed emergency
legislation which allowed it to push
through any covert restrictions
uh that it liked without parliamentary
scrutiny
but it was for a six-month period that
power now has to be renewed in
parliament
next week and there's a raw brewing in
the conservative party james forsyth
writes
the cover story about it in uh
the spectator this week uh tory mps are
trying to put a parliamentary
lock on any new covert restrictions and
by that they mean
that instead of writing a blank check
this time is pretty much they did
last time they would want to say on new
restrictions being implemented
graeme brady is the chair of the 1922
committee
of tory back ventures leading the back
bench effort
and he joins the program now graham
brady have you got the numbers to force
the government's hand on this
i think we have got the numbers we
tabled the amendment this afternoon
before the
rise of the house the amendment has got
i think
something just over 45 names on it
crucially we have uh more than 40
conservative
mps signing it but also support from the
other side of the house as well we have
labour mps and unionists
among the signatories so you think at
this stage that you
you have the votes to win even against a
government
with a notional 80-seat majority
well of course an awful lot depends on
what the official opposition does
but assuming that the opposition parties
vote in favor
of more parliamentary scrutiny then we
would have the numbers to
win a division uh we've got the numbers
just amongst the people who signed the
amendment there are actually an awful
lot more who've indicated they would
support
the amendment if it comes to a division
uh but i my strong personal preference
would be to reach an agreement with the
government
without having to go to the trouble of
holding a vote
on the amendment and i've had some good
constructive discussions
and i'm very hopeful we may be able to
get there
what do you say to those that argue look
at pandemic is an emergency
the government has to move quickly can't
always be going
to the commons to get a vote to endorse
its action
what do you say to that well the wording
of the amendment calls for the ministers
to
use reasonable endeavors so we we have
tried to take account of the possibility
there could be a
an unreasonable time pressure but the
other really important thing andrew
is the government has got a whole
different piece of legislation that it
can use
under the civil contingencies act it
could do nearly all of the things that
it's been doing
using the public health act of 1984.
the difference is that the
content some very stringent
requirements of is done under the
terms of the act so really what we're
trying to do
is bring the coronavirus act and
the public health act of 1984 into line
with what the civil contingencies act
would uh require uh which is some proper
parliamentary scrutiny
but the government will retain still
powers to do anything that needs to do
quickly
are the conservative benches in tune
with public opinion here are out of tune
because although in the media and in the
political circles there's been a lot of
criticism of the government locked down
and going back
again to a partial lockdown the
opinion polling suggests that only about
13 percent
of voters are against what the
government's doing when it comes
to lockdown well you've got two
different things here andrew the first
is the question of whether government
should be subject to
proper scrutiny whether it should be
held accountable by parliament
and i think virtually everybody agrees
that that should be done
and when you get the sort of shocking
headline that members of parliament
actually want to do more work
in return for their salaries and would
actually like to do the job
of parliamentary scrutiny that we're
paid to do
that i think does command strong public
support
when you then look at the individual
measures
i think you've got a whole spectrum of
different views the spectrum views
amongst those
members who have signed the amendments
some of them i think are in tune
with the government's policies but would
like more scrutiny
others are more skeptical i tend to lean
more towards
trusting people to make their own
decisions giving them good advice
and trying to work with the grain of
human nature
it seems what you're saying then this
isn't just a matter of process
in the sense that if we're going to have
restrictions on our freedom
the common should have it say and either
vote for
or against what the government is
proposing i get from what you're saying
is that you think that perhaps
government lockdown policy hasn't always
been right
oh i i've certainly got reservations
about the lockdown policy and i think
the
effect of the lockdown that we had
earlier in the year seems to have been
to
push the rising infections to a period
later in the year
and you know obviously i'm i defer to uh
to flavio
uh his uh i'm sure superior knowledge of
these things
but looking at the pictures of what's
happening in sweden
now it does look as though we've managed
to make this coincide
with the onset of colds and flu in the
autumn and winter
whereas sweden has got falling infection
rates at this point
so i've got i've got considerable um
skepticism
about many aspects of what has been done
but what i would say is that regardless
of whether you're skeptical
of the overarching policy the government
has followed
or not skeptical that parliamentary
scrutiny
should improve the process of government
it should make it less likely that
governments will make silly mistakes
it should also allow the public to see
much more clearly what the rationale is
for government decisions
and you know classic case in point when
scotland decided to exclude
primary school children from the
so-called rule of six but england didn't
there was never any explanation given of
that we hear
time after time from government
ministers uh the primary school children
are very unlikely to catch covert 19
and very unlikely to spread it uh well
if that is the case
then we maybe should have excluded them
from the rule of six like they did in
scotland
interesting james your uh cover story on
this
this week was very much on conservative
unrest on the back benches what would
you like to ask
graeme brady so i looking at the
signatures on the amendment what strikes
me
is the breadth of support it's kind of
very tempting when you saw steve baker
uh supporting the amendment on the
pesting show last night
to think that this is just the kind of
libertarian wing of a tory party who
caused trouble for
mrs may now causing trouble for mr
johnson
but i'm struck by the fact that damian
green theresa may's deputy prime
minister has signed it
bob neal very much on the left of the
party harriet baldwin another former
remainer has signed it
along with you know ian duncan smith
phillip davis
yeah and steve baker how broad
in the tory parliamentary policy is the
support for this
great well very broad support in the
parliamentary conservative party
essentially
most members of parliament and certainly
most conservative members of parliament
do believe in parliament and believe in
the
process of scrutiny the duty of holding
governments to account
and believe that that process can
improve government decision making
but maybe you're going to go on to say
james but
i'll make sure we cover it it's also
critically important i'm delighted that
we've got support from the other side of
the house
that my opposite number for instance
john cryer
the chairman of the parliamentary labour
party is amongst the signatories
so what i hope this will be seen as is
an absolute determination
from the back benches on both sides of
the house that we are going to insist on
a more open
uh process of decision making from
government that we're not going to see
all of this done behind closed doors
there will have to be debates
on the floor of the house in advance of
emergency
powers being implemented and there will
also have to be an opportunity for the
house of commons
to express its view my instinct is that
so far
the government probably would have won
all or nearly all of the votes that it
it could have held um but that may
change if this goes on for
for a very long time grant brady stick
with us because we'll be coming to
questions very shortly
but before we do let has turned to iran
now as the uk negotiates its future
relationship with the eu one part of
that relationship
doesn't seem to have changed our
approach to iran
in october the us arms ban on iran is
the u.n
arms ban i should say is up for renewal
the americans want to use a mechanism in
the iran nuclear deal
to extend the ban but remember mr trump
took america
out of that deal two years ago and the
e3 nations that's france germany
and the uk they wrote to the un saying
that the u.s
has no say in what happens to iran
now that it has left the nuclear deal a
clear difference of opinion there
between london
and washington so what does it mean for
british foreign policy and american
attitudes
to brexit britain we're joined by
dominique green deputy editor of the
spectators
us edition bit of a dilemma for britain
now wants to
be friends with the united states but he
still wants to be friends with europe
even as we leave
uh what how serious is this dominique
well andrew one of the things we
wouldn't have expected to have happened
this year
uh would be that britain would have
twice have found itself at odds with the
us
uh first over huawei and and then over
uh iran and and what used to be called
the iran deal
um when i interviewed mike pompeo
secretary of state
last week about this he was uh quite
explicit he says that he and i quote
expect britain france and germany to do
their bit
uh and when i'd interviewed him a few
weeks earlier he said we regret
their opposition and that's diplomatic
speak for
we cannot quite believe in fact that
britain in particular
at a moment when it needs support of the
trump administration
would be working against the american
interest
at the u.n now you uh
have done this interview with the
american secretary of state uh it's a
it's in the spectator u.s website i
think it's going to be the next print
edition of spectator
usa as well what did you make of him and
his attitude to britain
i was struck by the fact that he clearly
has the information and he has a clear
understanding of the world this is
something which uh president trump is
frequently criticized for lacking
uh in the case of pompeo he seemed a
very clear idea of where he believed
american interests currently lie and how
they can be secured in a multi-polar
21st century system i believe also that
he like most people in the trump
administration is very well disposed
towards britain it hasn't quite reached
the kind of polarization that many other
issues have reached but
the republican party generally is quite
anglophile um
and in recent years the democrats have
become notably less anglophile they're
much more likely
to be to take a position favoring the
european union for instance
in the brexit negotiations has uh
secretary pompeo has he developed a
new kind of foreign policy under the
trump administration we've seen
new policies for china tougher lines in
a tougher line
with iran as well but we've also seen a
diplomatic breakthrough
between israel and some arab states we
didn't quite expect mr trump to have
much of a foreign policy
uh profile but he seems to have
developed one does mr pompeo deserve
some of the credit
uh i believe he deserves an enormous
amount of the the credit for this and
there is a coherence to it
um he calls it principled realism and
and it sounds like he was trying to
thread a middle path
between the neoconservative enthusiasm
for trying to force
the rest of the world to be be american
in some way and the opposing
isolationist impulse which would simply
like the rest of the world to go away
which is not practicable um and he's
trying to compromise between the two
things
and and like most compromises you'll
find the value of it
when it hits the rock and and this
showdown which we're heading for at the
united nations is is the kind of crunch
moment at which we're going to see
just how much uh influence the united
states retains over its traditional
allies
just how much their previous promises or
even their
quietly stated off the record promises
are worth because i am hearing
that they're saying no don't worry don't
worry we will try and compromise with
you but there's been no public sign of
that at all
so this will be a real test for the
long-term viability of the policy that
pompeo has tried to create
well kind of just finally uh dominick of
this what sort of wiggle room
does britain have as we head to the
showdown over iran
at the u.n well it has it has virtually
no wiggle room in the sense that france
and germany can get through this
and afford to annoy the americans but uh
the trump administration i'm i'm told
in washington will remember this if it
is slighted at the u.n
uh you get the impression that all three
of the e3
uh governments are banking on a joe
biden victory
and a much more conciliatory approach to
the iran issue from an incoming biden
administration
but i i wouldn't bet anything on that
the one thing we can guarantee at the
moment
in the us is that the polls are
generally unreliable
and anything can happen okay dominique
thanks for that
let's move now to your questions and
here's an interesting question
uh graeme brady let me put this to you
the question is what is the chance that
the government will complete their
agenda
the one they got elected on in december
of last year
given uh brexit and covert
and all the rest of it i mean it's quite
hard is it not for the government to
stay on this agenda when
it's being bashed on all sides by covert
well of course brexit was a very
important part of the agenda that
it was elected to deliver and i think
that will be
uh and of course most of us still hope
that it'll be delivered with
at least a kind of free trade agreement
in place
by the end of the year and i think
that's entirely possible
but certainly the pandemic and the
response to the pandemic have become
not only uh consuming of time and energy
but
massively of money and the
effect on the economy is is going to be
i suspect long lasting
and for those businesses and you know i
think very much
adjacent to my constituency i've got
manchester airport
uh the aviation sector is very very
important as a local
employer and you know it's a very big
concern
that we still have that big uh
sector of the economy in deep freeze and
no
clear plan set out as to how we we get
it moving again
and uh you know so there's going to be a
unless we can
really get economic life happening again
uh this is going to occupy most of next
year
uh as well flavor here's one for you
one of our viewers wants to know should
we be putting the number of
cases into perspective in other words
should we be comparing them more to the
rate of testing
to the fatality rate to the
hospitalization rate
and even taking into account what our
questions are called
false positives well i i don't see that
we need to choose we can look at all of
them as indicators of the situation
we're facing
we don't just look at inflation numbers
we look at inflation numbers
uh jobless numbers and all sorts of
indicators
i don't think we need to focus on just
one indicator the government has been
focusing on cases i mean i remember in
the early days
i think at the point i've made of the
press conferences
that they talked about hospitalizations
they were worried about the nhs
they talked about deaths because the
fatality rate was
very high but now all the emphasis seems
to be
on cases which of course is the metric
which is rising most of all
but it surely has to be put into context
sure
i i think maybe it's useful to to draw a
distinction between what is being
communicated what is actually
the foundation of the actual decision
making i can i can i can assure you that
the
the actual discussions taking place in
sage and other places like that
are extremely detailed and and and all
encompassing
and but that might not be the best kind
of
of information for for public
consumption i'm not saying they're
trying to conceal things
but i mean just something as simple as
the r0 number which
which now everybody knows a little bit
about has been difficult to communicate
so i think it's okay to look at a few
headline figures
to make the case and then if if people
are really interested and so inclined
they can go into the nitty-gritty but i
don't think we should we should fall
into the trap of thinking
that this is the just the simplistic way
that the decisions are being made just
looking at one indicator
here's a question from darren wilcock uh
will boris johnson last until the next
election as prime minister
katie uh i definitely think the
the number of conversations of mps where
they raise us as a question
has gone up in recent weeks um there is
a
definitely a story in the times at the
weekend that sat the cat among the
pigeons slightly talking about
whether boris johnson um is up to the
task is enjoying it
and but i still think it's probably more
likely than not that he does
i think there is interest in the number
of people who are talking about rishi
sunak as their prime minister in waiting
and i think that's in part because if
you look at the residents in number 10
and number 11
the resident number 11 i think is closer
to the parliamentary party
when it comes to things like lockdown
the approach to coronavirus
and and i think that's partly why people
are looking to him but
i don't think boris johnson is going to
step away just yet
but james one of the things mr johnson
was supposed to do
in late summer and this early autumn was
to kind of re-establish the agenda that
he got elected on despite covert
to point the way forward his leveling up
agenda
and all the rest over dealing with the
problems of the red wall
constituencies and a key part of that
was meant to be the budget the budget
was meant to be
forward-looking uh response to getting
the agenda
back on track well we're not having a a
budget so
how did they get the agenda back on
track
i think realistically if you are looking
at six months more of these kind of
restrictions as boris johnson said in
his
televised address to the country on
tuesday night when the political agenda
isn't going to return to normal before
then and i mean the challenge for him is
to come up with a
post-covert agenda one thing that i
think could change the mood
is a brexit deal and i think that i
think the mood among the
negotiators on the uk side is much more
positive than it was
i think if he gets a deal there that
will put some petrol back
in his tanks it will give him some
momentum
but i think the big question for him is
this is after the first
wave of kobit boris johnson came out and
gave a speech and said
essentially now my election agenda is
more relevant than ever
i think the challenge now is covid is
clearly going to wreak
permanent changes on our economy and our
society
and i think what number 10 needs to be
ready with is essentially a new agenda
for next spring when they come forward
and say right this is how we are going
to adjust
to this post-covered world which even if
a vaccine or some kind of mass testing
breakthrough happens
is going to be very different from the
world pre-code
kate a lot of people are asking the
government's spending a lot of money on
things
what have we got to show for it i mean
one example coming up is i saw that the
government
is spending or has spent 12 billion
pounds on test and trace
what have we got for that that's an
excellent question andrew we've had a
lot of u-turns we've had a lot of delays
now as of today in england and wales you
can download a contact tracing app
people are encouraged to do so but the
times reports that you're also getting a
lot of
false positives there because the way
that the bluetooth works
just isn't quite good enough and of
course this is the scheme that the
government said months ago would be
world beating would be what we would use
to get out of this crisis before a
vaccine became available
and whilst the government is pushing
this contact tracing app and we'll see
in the coming weeks and months how
successful it is
it doesn't quite feel like that silver
bullet it's an incredible amount of
money to spend
now i think you'll struggle to find any
economist on the left or the right
who didn't think that spending now was a
good idea on larger
kobit 19 measures that this was such a
unique situation
if the government has any roles to step
in when there's a pandemic
and to spend money to make sure that
public health is protected as much as
possible
to try to keep the economy afloat but i
think we're going to hear more and more
stories
not just of government mismanagement of
money but you're also i think going to
find out more about companies that
potentially abused
the furlough scheme as we go into the
job support scheme that's really aimed
at small and medium-sized businesses if
you're a large firm that wants to use
the scheme
you're going to have to prove eligible
that you really took a hit
from kovan 19 and that your profits
suffered which means they're going to
have to
come out into public most likely and
make the case and
i think the public's going to judge in
the public sector and the private sector
just how well their tax money was spent
grain brady according to the spectator
the government's had 12
major u-turns in recent months i mean
it's
does u-turn so often most of us are
dizzy trying to keep up with them
and uh and 12 billion for a test and
trace system that is only
now coming in and is still full of
problems i mean you
you wouldn't exactly file this
government's record under c for
competence would you
well you know i think the big concern
with test and trace as i understand it
is that
it's actually much less effective when
you have high numbers
of positive tests uh it works well when
you've got very low
levels of infection you can actually
nail where the infections are breaking
out and trace
relatively few people and contain it so
you know
i'm certainly not persuaded that it's a
great sort of uh
solution to uh all of the problems that
that we face
uh i i think on the whole load so i'd
rather see uh
sensible u-turns than uh the dogged
pursuit of uh their sensible policies
so you know i've been pushing one on my
own for quite a long time which would be
a u-turn uh on the quarantine
policies and and start to get something
more uh
flexible in place like so many other
countries like germany has had for
months
uh that will allow uh people to travel
more easily but with a degree
of certainty that it's safe flavio the
behavior seems to be very important in
dealing with this
when we look at sweden we look at a
population
which has been asked to be
self-disciplined
and it seems it has been
self-disciplined and the results seem
quite encouraging in
japan there's been only 1500 dead
in nine months it's a lot but a lot less
than almost anywhere else
and again behavioral reasons are
one of the reasons given why japan has
such a low death rate
is that has different behavior in
different nations
produce different outcomes
well first of all let me just point out
that sweden is not
necessarily the the success story you
seem to suggest i mean if you look at
cumulative debts per
per capita they're doing worse than
something like denmark
which is very comparable in many
respects having said that there are
clearly cultural differences that
that make uh make a difference as
sweden is often touted as as a country
where there's a lot of trust in
government
and where people who are willing to go
and go you know go along with what is
being suggested
but there's another thing which is that
even for the same number of infections
in another country
it could be that sweden's health sector
is just so efficient
that that they deal with the problem uh
better once it arrives even
if we were to control for the number of
infections but in care homes they didn't
they had a disaster
in care homes just like we had and
friends had
yeah absolutely this is absolutely true
this is one of the big failures of
of the swedish approach to that they
focused very strongly
on shielding the the at-risk people
rather than closing down everything but
then
in the event they actually didn't manage
to ring
you know to to to protect the care homes
as they had intended to do
this is absolutely correct donate
question for you
here uh is kanzuk the way forward for
the uk
first of all what is kanzuk and is it
the way forward
it's the option that the uk could join
uh an international free trade
organization with canada australia
new zealand and so on well it's it's
it's an option but
um i i should imagine that any uh trade
strategy that excludes the united states
is going to be difficult and that's the
one which has been touted uh by
boris johnson before and after becoming
prime minister as the option that he
would want to go for and it is the one
that the trump administration
is still willing to give
is mr biden if he is the next incumbent
of the white house
will the biden administration be more
hostile to britain
well there was a little foretaste of
this last week which was pure
electioneering which was biden taking a
position
on the question of the hard border uh in
on the island of ireland
um and this i i would suggest had
nothing to do with the european union or
british government had everything to do
with american irish votes in a couple of
counties in swing states
pennsylvania in particular um that said
uh biden was obama's vice president and
obama famously uh said the britain would
be at the back of the queue
so it's very hard to believe that
anything has happened subsequently uh
that would warm
the biden administration's view towards
the uk well the moment he used the word
q
we knew that phrase had been drafted for
him by the british government
because if it had been an american word
he would have said back of the line
uh which is what americans say queue is
a very british word on that
kitty finish it up for us we've we've
had this
extra lockdown come in we've had these
figures to scare us
about the new cases we've now had the
winter economic plan that sounds like
something the kremlin would have come up
with
uh but anyway we will call it the winter
economic plan what happens next
are we are we in for a period of quiet
of two weeks or so
until we see how all this pans out or
are there more developments on the way
i think what's interesting is if you
look at the what we often hear from the
government is
it takes two weeks to know if a rule is
working yet
they haven't actually given lots of
these measures two weeks to see if they
work so if you look at the rule of six
we didn't have that for two weeks before
we got new restrictions
so i think that it's quite clear the
direction we're going in
in a way the announcement this week was
heralded as a win for the hawks people
like rishi zunak because it wasn't that
full
circuit break mini lockdown we heard
about but the direction of travel is
more restrictions
and i personally think the next one will
be looking at what they've done in
scotland
where nicolas sturgeon has said you know
you can't go to another household
i imagine that will come pretty soon and
and i don't think that we are at the it
has to be every two weeks i think they
could come
thick and fast and that's currently
where i think number 10 is
james surely if if the government
really believed that we were heading for
50 000 new cases
a day by the beginning of october it
wouldn't have come up with these
extra milk and water lockdown it would
have gone for the full monty
i mean the government's action suggests
it doesn't really believe its own
propaganda
so as i say in the magazine this week
andrew as
of on last friday boris johnson was
planning for a tougher set of
restrictions i think some of his
parliamentary allies boy this was going
to bring on a full confrontation with
this parliamentary party
and i think it's not it's a it's a badly
worse kept secret in westminster that
chris whitley and patrick valance would
like boris johnson to go further in
terms of restrictions
and just before we came on our android
the new case data was out for today and
that's
6634 new cases that's almost double the
number of new cases this time
last week and i think if we see these
numbers continuing to go up
i've increased with you and patrick
balance will be knocking on boris
johnson's door
and demanding more restrictions and i
think he
he here compromised but in the same way
that that as katie said that rule of six
was given only ten days to make an
impact
i think if we see the cases continuing
to go up i think he will as katie said
start banning household mingling that
that is the thing that the scientists
think really makes the difference
and i think he will do that because
clamping down on non-economic
socializing
it is a less of a big decision in terms
of the economy and employment
than closing hospitality would be which
is the other thing
that some of the people on sage would
like him to do
okay james thanks for that and your
thanks to all of my guests tonight i
know the
problems will soon be closing at 10
o'clock in uh
good old blighty so i'm going to let you
all get away so that you can practice
some early evening
drinking and to those watching us as
well thanks for joining
the week in 16 minutes we'd love to find
out what you thought of it
how we can improve it we know there's
plenty of room for improvement
so send through any thoughts to
spectator tv at spectator dot co dot uk
and our thanks once again not just to
our guests but to our very supportive
sponsor
the natwest group there's a special
offer for our spectator tv audience for
a limited time
you can subscribe to the spectator print
and online
for just a pound a week and you get a 20
pound amazon gift voucher
absolutely free go to
www.spectator.comuk
forward slash trial and become a
subscriber today almost 100
000 people are doing that already you
join the gang they can all be wrong
thanks for watching today we hope you'll
join us again next thursday at 6 p.m
london time for another the week in 60
minutes
until then bye bye
[Music]
you